the majority of what police do under the  fourth of july is illegal fireworks  related according to metro assistant  sheriff brett zimmerman last year we had  probably 11 thousand calls for service  on the fourth of july 7 000 of them were  firework related  uh what we usually do for enforcement is  we will  team our officers up with our task force  it's made up of  also henderson north las vegas some  other jurisdictions that assist with us  and and our and our partners over at the  fire department  uh and we will go out and uh and enforce  the illegal fireworks ordinances and  also confiscate the firearms  that is where our partners with the fire  department really help out because they  have the expertise in handling those  the actual firework and disposing of it  safely  well that was on the morning cup of joe  segment on good day las vegas  every wednesday